I don't think there's anything wrong
with average Pokemon looks alone
I mean I think like there's nothing
wrong with being average I think if you
take 10 girls at the table like half of
us probably are average yeah I think no
one wants to be like honest with
something isn't just because you're not
saying you're a 10 doesn't mean you're
not confident either there's a
difference between realistic and just
not confident I agree completely yeah I
just I don't know why like we live in
this Society where average is seen as a
bad thing like most people are average
not everyone can be like if you think
about if you're an eight that means
you're in the top 20 of beauty you
should have had top 20 of beauty results
so that means um I don't know modeling
contracts I don't know you know um
eligible top 20 10 men in your DMs or
um have you seen it not not just like
like Siri taking you seriously